imaginez imaginez un monde dans lequel
vos collègues vous accueillerez chaque
matin avec douceur avec bienveillance
avec gentillesse
imaginez un monde dans lequel les
passants vous sourirez comme ça
gratuitement sans rien attendre en
retour
imaginez un monde dans lequel vos
voisins hier des inconnus serait
aujourd'hui vos amis imaginez un monde
dans lequel la solitude n'existerait pas
un monde dans lequel la compétition
aurait laissé place à la coopération et
à la solidarité
là je sais ce que vous vous dites ces
deux là ils sont complètement rêveur la
dernière fois que j'ai souri à une
passante dans la rue et s'est enfui en
courant pour changer de trottoir et hier
matin quand je suis arrivé au bureau
mes collègues avaient plutôt cette tête
là
il pouvait aussi avoir cette tête là et
pourtant il est possible de changer le
monde
et si pour cela il vous suffisait
d'appuyer sur un bouton le feriez vous
appuyez vous sur ce bouton
ma mère est malgache je suis né à
madagascar et j'ai grandi à la réunion
jusque là tout va bien mon père est
libanais ma grand-mère et grecs
mon nom de famille et l'italien est sur
mon passeport apparaît pas moins de
quatre prénoms vous avez suivi parce que
moi je me perdais tout le temps mais
dont vous ça avec la réunion il y à au
moins un point commun le métissage ci
est une force que je n'ai compris ce que
bien plus tard car quand on est jeune
c'est plutôt source de confusion qui
j'étais et puis ya vu une grande
mélancolie aussi qui soulignait mon
incompréhension du sens que l'on donné à
la vie alors je ne voulais qu'une seule
chose partir quitter la réunion à tout
prix pourquoi parce qu'elle ne répondait
pas à mes questions
et parce que la mer le ciel ne m'offrait
qu'un seul horizon
maman s'est réveillée un matin avec un
simple mal de tête
les seules choses dont je me souvienne
ce sont les taches bleues qui sont
apparus sur son corps la perte des
cheveux une unique visite à l'hôpital
parce que les enfants de mon âge ne
pouvaient pas accéder à ces services
je me souviens aussi d'un drôle
d'appareil est tout bleu qu'on lui avait
apposé sur le thorax
mon papa m'expliqua plus tard qu'on ne
pouvait plus lui faire des piqûres
ailleurs sur son corps il fallait lui
injecter directement les médicaments
dans ce petit tube la leucémie l'a
emporté elle avait 33 ans
je ne sais ces deux événements sont liés
mais j'ai par la suite développé un
syndrome donc s'était généralisé très
puissant attaques de panique crise
d'angoissé anxiolytiques antidépresseurs
psychologue 6,4 des guérisseurs même en
l'espace d'une décennie
j'étais devenu un expert de la peur
certains soirs les yeux rivés au plafond
tu ne l'est pas certain d'avoir la force
de pouvoir les réouvrir le lendemain
matin
mais voyez vous je me suis battue je me
suis accrochée j'ai fait de longues et
bonnes études
si bien qu'à 25 ans armé de - m billet
j'étais cadre j'avais un bon salaire une
bonne voiture une moto des vêtements des
meubles
j'avais tout je n'avais rien il me
fallait du sens il me fallait du sens à
ma souffrance il me fallait du sens à la
souffrance alors en 2006 rattrapé par
l'urgence avec nina nous quittons tous
amis famille patrie et nous embarquons
prend lé aventures de notre vie notre
quête spirituelle surtout n'ayez pas
peur de ce mot spirituel signifie
simplement la quête du sens la poursuite
du sacré
alors nous voilà partis sur les routes
du monde avec les mêmes aspirations et
avec la promesse de sa compagne et
mutuellement dans nos chemins respectifs
je suis parti à la recherche de réponses
dont les questions étaient peu claires
qu'importe je voulais expérimenter la
vie en cinq ans j'ai parcouru la
nouvelle zélande du nord au sud avec un
vieux vannes il y avait tellement de
trous qu'il faisait plus froid à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur
je me suis réveillé en plein outback
australien perdu au milieu des
kangourous sauvage je me suis même
retrouvé à faire mes courses de noël en
avion à madagascar la soute était pleine
de caisses de champagne
je vous dis pas l'atterrissage quand j'y
repense c'était magique comme au cinéma
et pourtant celle aventure humaine qui
m'a le plus transformer ce sont les gens
qui m'ont le plus appris ils m'ont
accueilli chez eux dans leur maison
comme un membre de leur famille perdue
et ramper sous la pluie un japonais m'a
offert son parapluie
en thaïlande une maman est venue mais
confie son histoire ses rêves ses peurs
en espagne après une longue journée de
travail
un chauffeur de bus m'a offert un bon
bout en forme de coeur juste pour me
donner le sourire
ces gens étaient tous des inconnus
et pourtant leur sourire leur
bienveillance leur générosité leur
compassion mon réchauffer le coeur je me
sentais existait des gens ordinaires ont
rendu ma vie extra ordinaire
des confins de l'himalaya jusqu'au
temple sacré du triangle d'or entre la
birmanie le laos et la thaïlande des
plus anciens monastères d'océanie ou
d'europe
je suis allé à la rencontre de ses
maîtres ces hommes et ces femmes qu'on
dit avoir transcendé la souffrance avoir
transcendé la souffrance j'ai étudié
j'ai écouté leur enseignement et je suis
allé chercher au plus profond de moi mes
propres réponses
plus j'avançais sur ce chemin et plus je
découvrais cette incroyable vérité nous
sommes tous les mêmes
nous sommes entrés à la réunion en 2011
riche comble est rempli et pourtant
surprenamment cette étape allait être la
plus difficile lorsqu'on par quinze
jours en vacances et qu'on revient c'est
déjà compliqué de faire face à son
quotidien
images et vous imaginez-vous partir cinq
années côtoyé 25 culture frôlé la mort
et parfois même côtoyé votre propre mort
votre propre finitude
lorsque vous revenez chez vous c'est
votre référentiel dans sa globalité qui
vole en éclats fait on a appuyé sur ce
bouton on a ouvert la porte de la maison
à des inconnus pour venir partager un
repas un moyen pour continuer le voyage
un moyen aussi pour ne pas s'enfermer
dans ses idées dans ses croyances
parce que la vérité est bien c'est
l'autre
la vérité c'est l'autre et je m'en
souviens comme si c'était hier
je regardais dans le journal sur la page
de gauche il avait cette interview celle
d'un entrepreneur qui avait bâti un très
beau projet une très belle initiative en
plein coeur des camélias ici même à
saint denis de la réunion un centre de
massage traditionnel et de bien-être
je me suis dit c'est vraiment auprès des
gens comme ça que je grandis c'est
vraiment en rencontrant des gens comme
ça que je me transforme alors j'ai pris
mon téléphone pour l'inviter à venir
manger un repas chez nous en toute
humilité
évidemment lorsque fut tombé sur son
secrétariat
tout le monde a bien rigolé et déjà
prévenu mais sur la page de droite il y
avait un deuxième portrait une deuxième
interview celle de ceux podologue qui
bien qu'à ta d'une très grave maladie et
en dépit de tous les pronostics des
médecins avaient gravi les plus hauts
sommets du monde
lorsque je les ai invités
il a immédiatement accepté et nous avons
passé une soirée magique
cela fait maintenant plus de deux ans
que nous invitons des inconnus avaient à
manger à la maison à partager un repas
que ce soit des podologues des
entrepreneurs des artistes des inconnus
des voyageurs d'ici ou d'ailleurs
c'est à chaque fois une très grande
source de partage une très belle source
d'inspiration
toujours pour cultiver le partage un
après midi avec nirina nous nous sommes
mis à faire des cookies dans le but
avoué d'aller les partager ensuite dans
la rue aux passants aux commerçants en
échange d'un sourire pour recréer du
lien entre les gens il faut aller faire
des courses revenir à la maison
les préparer les façonner un par un les
cuirs faire la vaisselle et bien sûr les
distribuer je sais ce n'est pas facile
ça demande du temps sa demande de
l'énergie
ça demande du courage même mais
croyez-nous ou plutôt nous
ne nous croyez pas essayer fait des
cookies en oeuvrant pour le bonheur des
autres
si votre propre bonheur que vous
cultivez moi je vous propose dès à
présent de venir goûter en direct la
fournée de ce matin c'est quelqu'un veut
bien se lever s'il vous plaît merci
merci merci merci merci
merci
jamais jamais nous n'oublierons le
visage et le regard de cette caissière
lorsque nous lui avons apporté ces
petits coups qui sont contraints
n'allait pas être renouvelée elle venait
de perdre son travail elle s'est mise à
pleurer
elle s'est mise à pleurer un simple
petit coup qui devenait soudainement une
très grande marques d'humanité
il est possible de construire un monde
meilleur
il est possible d'être heureux nous tous
ici dans cette salle vraiment que nous
habitue à madagascar mayotte maurice les
sept milliards d'êtres humains
nous aspirons tous à la même chose nous
aspirons tous au bonheur qui parmi vous
et je vais demander la lumière s'il vous
plaît qui parmi vous n'a jamais souffert
lever la main levé la main et regardez
autour de vous qui n'a jamais souffert
ici
évidemment nous sommes tous les mêmes
ce que nous aimerions avec nirina c'est
dès à présent que nous changerons le
monde ensemble ici maintenant que
ensemble nous appuyons sur ce bouton
vous voulez bien
vous voulez bien je vais vous demander
de vous lever s'il vous plaît je vais
vous tous ensemble on va partir et pour
une petite méditation
je vais vous demander s'il vous plaît de
prendre les mains des personnes qui sont
à vos côtés
très bizarre
maintenant fermez les yeux fermés les
yeux
êtes vous en mesure de sentir la chaleur
dans les mains que vous tenez
essayez de vous concentrer
on lutte contre des automatismes de
défense mais si on ouvre son coeur
êtes vous capable de sentir la chaleur
qui émane de cette marque vous tenait
maintenant réfléchissez cette personne à
mes côtés tout comme moi a été un enfant
cette personne à mes côtés tout comme
moi à des rêves
moi cherche le bonheur cette personne
dont je tiens les mains peut-être
at-elle souffert la perte d'un être cher
la solitude la maladie
peut-être sept personnes souffrent hôtel
à 7 secondes même changé le monde
ça commence par un simple souhait
tourner vers l'autre
je vous propose à présent de ré ouvrir
les yeux
car désormais le monde a changé
merci